[Music]
the 2000 presidential election between
the former vice president
al gore and then governor of texas
george w bush was
extremely close with only 500 votes in
the key swing state of florida
separating the two candidates
many people today look back on bush's
win in 2000 with skepticism
citing the fact that the vote counting
in florida where jeb bush was the
governor at the time was halted before
all the votes could be tallied
leading the supreme court to
preemptively award the presidency to
bush
in fact the 2000 election has been
called a turning point in the decay of
the american democracy
however in the world of the scp
foundation
bush's presidential win in 2000 wasn't
just an example of shoddy ballot
counting and senate bias
but the result of a strange case
involving alien parasites
body switching smear campaigns and
farting
cows yes you heard that right this is
the story of scp-4444
and the entity simply known as garber
gore
scp-4444 was first discovered in 1999 by
agents ringwald and porterhouse of the
fbi's unusual incidence unit
also known as the uiu ringwald and
porterhouse had been tasked with
monitoring the phone calls of
then-president bill clinton
clinton was having a conversation with
joe andrew who was the chair of the
democratic national committee
joe was calling to report a couple
things about vice president gore
first that he was going to announce a
candidacy for the 2000 presidential bid
nothing too unexpected about that but
then he told joe that there was an
alien in his head this was followed by a
white house staffer witnessing him walk
right through a solid wall
given the strangeness of these claims
the uiu moved in to attempt to contain
the vice president
however this proved to be a tricky
situation because as joe had stated
al gore was able to walk through any
solid object
unsure what to do the uiu called in the
scp foundation for some much needed
backup
the nature of mr gore's anomalous
properties were such that it prompted
the foundation to create an entirely new
containment class
of which scp-4444 is the only
example the new class ticonderoga was
named after the iroquois word for an
intersection of two rivers
and fittingly the new containment class
represented an object that was in
between being contained
and not contained scp-4444 was to be
monitored
but not apprehended as any attempt to do
so would only aggravate his anomalous
properties
during the initial monitoring stage al
gore's home was scanned with infrared
cameras
in an attempt to discover what might be
causing the anomalies around the vice
president
what they found was surprising a long
hexagonal spike engraved with alien
glyphs
invisible to the naked eye and
apparently intangible as well
was protruding from the back of mr
gore's head
even though al gore could not be
contained the scp foundation was still
able to interview him to try and
ascertain the nature of the spike
and the anomalous properties it caused
present for the interview was gore
himself
scp site director alex mabel and fbi
associate director of special units adam
spironi
initially spironi was uncooperative and
gore himself dismissed director mabel's
claims
but midway through the interview he
started to emit a strange noise
like a radio being tuned wondering if
this was the spike trying to get in
contact
mabel asked is anyone else in there to
which he got this response wandanat
name of gabagar presented mabel tried to
respond by introducing himself
but al gore interrupted by addressing
the entity in the spike himself
well hang on now garber i haven't done
proper introductions yet
through the rest of the interview gore
explained his situation
the entity in his head called itself
garber gore and while it could
communicate verbally using his voice
there was a translation barrier that
meant that its speech patterns and
syntax were
often unintelligible gore had been aware
of his situation with garber for just a
few days
but in that time the two of them had
formed something of a bond
in fact garber was the one who convinced
gore to run for president
in the 2000 elections mabel asks garber
what it wanted on earth
to which it responded mind think the
sustenance of garber
salicious desire undertaking
encouragement downsize the conquest
strongest most strong garbage presented
misunderstanding
strongest misunderstanding vice
unequated goofy unnecessarity for
implementation garbage or on think stem
improvement situation by majority
gathering selectors the vote
garvagor succeed presidential
encouragement arrival the greater garber
al gore was quick to translate garber's
mangled speech
as far as he understood it garber had
been sent out as an emissary for his
species of inter-dimensional
planet-hopping parasites that feed on
thought
garber's intention was to implant
himself in the head of the most powerful
person on earth
in order to facilitate an easy
colonization
garber species were non-violent and
unable to stand up to any kind of
resistance
but if the leader of the free world was
already merged with one of them
it would make taking over the planet
that much easier
however in a misunderstanding of earth
culture garber had gone for the vice
president
instead of the actual commander-in-chief
bill clinton now garber's plan was to
fix that mistake
by having al gore win the presidency the
scp foundation obviously couldn't let
this takeover go
unchallenged even though garber's race
were peaceful
seeking only to use the thoughts of the
human race as a food source
further interviews and studies revealed
that they emitted insanely high levels
of carbon dioxide
to have a large number of them merge
with the human population would spell
total climate chaos
essentially hot boxing the earth to the
point it could no longer sustain life
even faster than humans are doing it
since there was no safe way to remove
the spike from the back of al gore's
head
more drastic measures had to be taken in
a meeting with the fbi
scp site director crowe presented a
possible solution
an incorporeal entity vacuum chamber
which the foundation had seen some
success with in detaining ghosts and
other apparitions
the only problem was anything placed in
the chamber would explode
and since garber couldn't be separated
from al gore's head
the results would be messy since the fbi
was unwilling to blow up the vice
president
that left only one choice the scp
foundation had to find a way to turn
american voters against al gore it
wouldn't be easy to do without
attracting suspicion
in fact it would be almost impossible
unless they were able to put a man
on the inside thankfully just such a
person
presented themselves during a meeting
the fbi delegates let the scp foundation
members know that while it hadn't been
leaked to the press yet
george w bush was in a coma in the
hospital after being hit by a stray
bullet during a hunting trip
his body was relatively undamaged but
doctors had little
hope of recovering his mind at this
point in the meeting
all the scp personnel presented turned
to look at dr bright
he was going to be their inside man
whether he liked it
or not the foundation visited the
hospital where governor bush was being
cared for
and moved him into foundation care
before he could be pronounced dead
there doctors finished patching up his
body and scp-963 was applied
allowing the spirit of dr jack bright to
take over his mind
jack bright masquerading as george bush
was now ready to run for office
the next step in the process was to
start a disinformation campaign against
al gore there were a few proposed smear
campaigns to be used against score
the first proposal was codenamed tar
belly a campaign that would have the
foundation blame gore for the pollution
of the water supply in a rural part of
the developing world
this one was dismissed for being too
outlandish the next was porky
which involved a rumor that al gore had
once been caught in a compromising
position with a pig
this one was dismissed due to not having
access to convincing photo editing
software
the third one was codenamed star wars
and it involved discrediting al gore by
saying that he believed he was in
contact with aliens
this was obviously shot down very
quickly due to being a little too close
to the truth for comfort
the proposal that was eventually settled
on was codenamed the other monika
and the story centered around the idea
that monica lewinsky was just an
innocent patsy taking the fall for the
person who bill clinton
really had relations with al gore
this rumor was the perfect combination
of solicious and being just believable
enough
making it the perfect thing to use to
smear al gore's reputation in a country
that still hadn't come around on gay
rights
while director crowe continued to refine
prototypes for the technology that would
allow the foundation to interact
physically with scp-444
the foundation staged an early september
debate between gore and dr bright posing
as george bush
the idea was to create a controlled
atmosphere and mitigate any potential
security risks
the debate was held in a church in
plainfield indiana
and moderated by jim lehrer during the
debate
garber gore did a lot of the talking for
his human host
resulting in some utterly incoherent
responses
when asked what makes him more qualified
for the role of president than governor
bush
gore responded when you see someone
sitting in that chair
you want to know for sure that they're
the best ambivalent vicarious corn crate
caliper available for the job
and you can be sure that a vote for
garber gore is an underestimated vote
for respectability
neutrality lampposts in the middle of
the debate
an audience plant brought up supposed
leaked photos of al gore and bill
clinton engaging in their illicit affair
the crowd was understandably shocked
yelling and screaming in response
now that the crowd was against al gore
dr bride went in for the kill
he asked the people in attendance do you
want to see a strong man in the chair
or a weak man under it at this point
something weird started to happen to the
people in the crowd
they started full-on rioting but then
they started to change
shape in fact the whole space started to
shift
al gore stood up and started waving his
arms shouting
garber unacceptable edition convention
terraform unto dark magicianship
spell spell people rushed towards the
exits but found them blocked by the
elongated forms of other members of the
audience
at this point the church was raided by
both foundation personnel and the fbi
garber gore fled from the scene
returning every attendee to normal as
soon as they were out of garber's line
of sight
the debate was pulled from television
and anyone who watched it live was
administered amnesty
additional amnestics were administered
to anyone who saw garber gore running
through solid objects as he fled from
indiana to western ohio
where he was found hiding in the loft of
a barn meanwhile dr bride was punished
by the ethics committee for his behavior
during the debate
and agreed to act in a more professional
manner for the october debates
most of al gore's campaign team were
undercover uiu
agents who used audio editing to iron
out some of the eccentricities of
garber's way of speaking before putting
ads out
most of them were able to be saved in
the edit but some were so off the wall
they could never be shown to the public
in one of them al gore stands in a field
of cows and talks about how much
greenhouse emissions are produced by
farting cows
he then gives his solution to this
problem taping plastic bags over the
backsides of every cow in america
another rejected garbage or campaign ad
that's much shorter but just as crazy
features a video of a sleeping cat
with al gore narrating about how
everyone should shave the backs of their
heads
on november 7 2000 election night
the scp foundation and the uiu watched
the results with baited breath
if gore won they'd have to be prepared
to use director crow's new vacuum
nullifier device to simultaneously
contain
scp-4444 and kill al gore
the scp foundation had killed public
figures before but never a president on
the eve of his election
but then florida started to tip in favor
of
bush after two days of recounting
despite losing the popular vote
dr jack bride in the body of george w
bush was named president
of the united states the foundation
expected an outburst from garber
but the entity remained silent in fact
al gore has never displayed anomalous
properties ever again
he conceded defeat graciously and more
or less retreated from the public eye
until the release of his film
an inconvenient truth that wasn't the
last the scp foundation ever heard
of scp-4444 though on november 11
2007 a mysterious broadcast aired on tvs
across gainesville florida that appeared
to be a lost al gore campaign ad
it shows gore sitting on a hill by the
sea in the distance something large
drops from the sky
al gore smiles and says i'm al gore
and i want to be your last american
president
now go check out scp-1981 ronald reagan
cut up while talking and
scp-095 and scp-3166 monster garfield
attack for more scps behind the scenes
of real life events